-All right, here's how
this works.
Michael Strahan,
you will start the round
by pressing start
on this buzzer, okay?
And then drawing a clue from
the top of the pile right there.
You have to get your teammate
to guess the clue
as quickly as possible
and then hand the buzzer off
to the person on your right.
You can make any physical
gesture, say whatever you want.
You can't say any word
in the actual clue.
Is it too long already?
[ Laughter ]
-We could have already
played a round.
[ Laughter ]
-But if you're holding
the buzzer when it goes off,
your team loses that round.
We're gonna play three rounds.
Let's take our positions.
Michael, you go here.
Other Michael, you go there.
-Michael, you're over there.
-Excuse me.
-Here we go.
All right, here we go.
-How you doing, man?
-Come on, come on, cut it out.
[ Laughter ]
-Here we go, man. Come on.
This is it.
-Tell me when you're ready.
-Yeah.
-We're ready. Ready. Okay.
[ Beeping ]
-When you have this thing
you break from a chicken
and you say I --
-Wishbone?
-Yes.
-That was good.
-Oh, my God.
[ Beeping intensifies ]
-Okay. Michael J. Fox was
a teen version of this?
-Teen wolf.
-Teen version of a...
-Wolf man.
[ Laughter ]
-Also called a...
-Werewolf.
-Yes.
[ Beeping intensifies ]
-Something you play in jazz.
-Trumpet. A saxophone.
-Yeah, there you go.
-All right.
It's snowing. Gosh!
What happened?
-All right, keep it going.
Keep it going.
In football, he's at the end of
the line --
[ Audience ohhs ]
[ Beeping intensifies ]
-Just tell me the clue.
[ Buzzer ]
-Rihanna!
-Can I say something?
We suck.
-No, no, we're bad at it.
-No, y'all suck!
-Oh, my goodness, come on.
You're my teammate.
-I'm kidding.
-Come on, here we go.
-Okay, okay.
-Right now, it is still 0-0.
-Big, big money.
Big, big money.
-Wait, how do you win?
-I just made it up
because there's no judges.
[ Laughter ]
All right. You have one.
You have one point.
-I was gonna say.
-All right.
-Come on, Michael.
-All right, here we go.
[ Beeping ]
Jim Carrey played him
in a Ron Howard movie.
He was in green prosthetics.
-Oh, the Grinch.
-There, he got it.
-A dad.
-No words. No words.
-Legally Blonde,
her dog was a --
What kind of dog was her dog?
Legally Blonde.
She carried around a little --
-A poodle?
-No. Taco Bell!
-Oh, Chihuahua.
-Nice!
-Sometimes you give this to us
for the holidays.
Like, it's a -- you spread it
on bread in the morning.
-Mayonnaise? Avocado!
-Yes.
-Avocado toast.
[ Beeping intensifies ]
-Okay. What you do in
a celebration, you...
-Chest bump, chest bump.
-What you gonna eat?
-Uh, uh, uh, mac and cheese.
[ Laughter ]
-Pizza in a wrap.
You put it in a toaster over.
It's a frozen-food thing.
-Uh, uh, DiGiorno.
[ Buzzer ]
[ Laughter ]
-Hey, I have a question.
He gifts you guys avocado toast?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Come on. Stop.
Stop it, man. Come on.
-You see, he knew what I was
talking about.
It's good.
-That's the worst gift ever.
[ Laughter ]
I'm out here giving out money,
and I could have just given
somebody avocado toast.
[ Laughter ]
-It's really special
avocado toast.
All right, guys.
We're gonna play one more round.
-Why not? We're here.
Let's do it.
-Well, yeah, this is good.
The sourdough is
from San Francisco.
It's the real deal.
-Dude, I'll tell you right now.
You don't gift food.
-No, it's pretty good.
-Avocados?
-It's pretty good.
-Hey, man,
you've been brainwashed.
Avocado toast is not a gift.
[ Laughter ]
-It's delicious.
-All right. Here we go.
I love that you knew the dog
from "Legally Blonde."
[ Laughter ]
-Don't judge me.
-Watching that movie a lot.
All right, here we go.
This one is the final round.
This one is worth
1,000 points.
-Rightfully so.
-One point per round.
Now it's 1,000.
Let's do this, dude. Come on,
we got to work together.
We live together basically.
-Get your head in the game.
Let's go. Me?
My head is totally in the game,
man.
Get ready, man.
-Do it!
Whoo!
[ Beeping ]
-Come on, Jimmy!
-Okay, when you're at a prom
or something,
you're with your date
and you do a...
-A prom dance. A waltz.
A slow dance.
-That's right, slow dance.
-When you need -- this thing is
like sagging, you need to...
-Botox.
-No, you bring it up.
Bring it up! When they cut on
you, and they cut it up!
-Plastic surgery.
-No, they --
[ Beeping intensifies ]
-What?
-If I am picking you up, I am --
-Picking me up.
-If I go to the gym and I --
-Weights.
Lifting weights. Pump.
Face lift!
-Yes!
-Oh, my gosh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Du-du-du-du-du-du!
-Jackhammer!
-When you go here,
you're family.
-Ihop.
[ Buzzer ]
Applebee's!
Which one is that?
-Olive Garden.
-Oh man, I've never been to
Olive Garden.
[ Laughter ]
-You got to go.
Guys, the winners!
[ Cheers and applause ]
That was hilarious.
My thanks to Michael Strahan,
Michael Angarano,
and Tariq right there.